l'anc est sûre la disparition d'estelle
mouzin
c'était une fausse piste les fouilles
entreprises sous un restaurant asiatique
de seine et marne n'ont absolument rien
donné sur les dix personnes placées en
garde à vue tout ce soir ont été
relâchés edouard da costa jean d'un
arrière
beaucoup de bruit pour rien malgré un
renseignement jugé crédible par les
enquêteurs les fouilles d'envergure
menée dans ce restaurant n'ont rien
donné sous l'imposante dalle de béton
démoli en quelques heures les policiers
l'ont finalement découvert que trois
fragments d'os d'origine animale il n'y
avait aucune trace de cadavres d'enfants
l'avocat du père d'estelle mouzin
espérer une toute autre issue à ce qui
s'avère être une nouvelle fois une
fausse piste
je serai le dernier a reproché aux
policiers de mettre tout en oeuvre pour
chercher les raisons pour laquelle est
elle a disparu
donc moi je ne suis pas choqué condé
fois beaucoup de moyens pour essayer de
vérifier une piste d'aller chercher les
éléments et du côté de la famille
d'estelle c'est la demande qu'elle a il
faut tout faire pour retrouver les
raisons de la disparition d'estelle et
qui est à l'origine de cette disparition
ce soir le père d'estelle mouzin ne
comprend pas comment la police
judiciaire a pu accorder autant de
crédit aux renseignements fournis par un
journaliste indépendant qui enquêtait
sur le milieu sinois à paris vous ne
ferez pas dire que je suis abattu
comprenez bien que je ne tomberai pas
dans le piège de la compassion de la
tristesse mais la douleur et tout ça moi
je ne combats et les espaces
intermédiaires ne m'intéresse absolument
pas ces heures là aucune incidence sur
la suite à donner
les dernières personnes placées en garde
à vue ont été relâchées en fin d'après
midi aucune charge n'étant retenue
contre elle quant au préjudice subi par
le restaurateur dont l'établissement est
inutilisable
ce sera maintenant à la justice de le
dédommager